القوه الناعمه هو اسم اطلق في مصر على دار
رعايه المسنين الجديده التي افتتحت باشراف
نقابه الفنانين المصريين وذلك لضمان حياه
كريمه لشخصيات مصر الثقافيه والفنيه اسم
الدرج جاء من فكره هذه الشخصيات كانت من
وجوه القوه الناعمه المصريه كان لها اثر
في تاريخ مصر الثقافي والفني المبادره
تسعى لتكريم الفنانين الذين قدموا المتعه
والثقافه ثريه للمصريين والعرب خصوصا من
يتعرض منهم لازمه كبيره في السنوات كبرها
سمر رشاد مع تفاصيل
[موسيقى]
تتنافر صوره اخبار من حين الاخر عن فنان
كبير لا يجدو مسكنا بعد ما تقدم به العمر
او فنان يعيش وحيدا
من هنا كانت فكره دار للمسنين للفنانين
والفنانات او بمعنى ادق الحلم الذي راود
الكثيرين وطالب به عده مرات
[موسيقى]
واخيرا تحقق هذا الطموح بافتتاح دار القوه
النعمه اول دار للمسنين الفنانين من اعضاء
نقابه المهن التمثيليه بتبرع من سمو الشيخ
سلطان القاسمي حاكم الشارقه
الدار تستوعب 40 نزيلا من الفنانين ويوجد
ايضا عياده للرعايه الصحيه مكتبه وقع
للجنز
هذا المشروع يضمن للفنانين الذين اسروا
والشاشه والمسرح لسنوات طويله ان يعيش
حياه كريمه وامنه بعدما تقدم بهم العمر
وان ان حصلت عنهم الاضواء تظل اعمالهم
قائمه والتي شكلت قوه مصر الناعمه على
مدار اكثر من قرن سمر بشات لصباح العربيه
من القاهره
[موسيقى]
امانه مبادره جميله يعني دار مسنين
للفنانين يعني فكره جديده بس انا عندي
مشاعر متناقضه في هذا الموضوع انه دايما
فكره دار المسنين وانها وان كانت هي بترعى
المسنين والمتركين لوحدهم لكن فيها هيك
شعور مؤلم ومزعج انه يكون هذا انه مو سنه
يعيش وحيد في دار او ماوى للعجزه والمسنين
بس في المقابل عشان هيك بقول لك مشاعر
مزدوج انا في المقابل انه دائما الفنان
اللي بيكون تحت الاضواء كل الوقت وكل
هالحب والاعجاب والاهتمام والتقدير فجاه
بيوصل لمرحله
كيف مثلا اللاعبين الفوتبول بيكونوا
اساطير وبعدين بيلجاوا للمخدرات
فبالتالي دار المسنين
ايجابيات الساميه لكل المسلمين في العالم